JANET CONRAD: I would love
to try to teach physics
to first- to third-graders
using no equations,
only using examples and only
using little experiments
because there is just
an enormous amount
that you can learn by
looking at what is happening.
And one of the big concerns that
I have about the way physics
is taught is that we love to
go into all of the mathematics.
And I actually think
that people end up
divorced from what's going
on in the real world.
They start to understand
the mathematics really well,
but they actually
don't understand
the physical phenomena.
And physics is a contact sport.
You have to play with it, right?
You will not understand
angular momentum
until you have been spinning
around and pull your arms in
and suddenly you
go out of control.
You know?
It's those things that
you have to try in order
to really understand it.
And I believe that we can start
doing that at a very young age.
And the problem, of
course, is resources.
You need real resources
to be able to teach kids
things like that.
But right now, I can
teach a very small child
one of Maxwell's equations.
I can show you how we do it.
This is the one which says that
a moving magnetic field induces
current and also, currents
induce magnetic fields.
OK?
So what I have here is a
very heavy piece of copper.
It's actually a beam
pipe from ferry lab.
It's a pretty
thick piece, right?
And so it's copper, so
current can flow through it.
And I have here a magnet.
And I can drop my magnet in
and it takes a really long time
for the magnet to fall out.
And you can show this
to a two-year-old
and they will just
watch that forever.
They are so excited to see that
because they know something
is very seriously wrong here.
And what's happening is the
magnet is inducing a current,
and a current is inducing
a magnetic force opposite
of that magnetic field.
And it's preventing this
thing from falling as fast
as it would.
And, you know,
second-graders will get this.
And then when they
finally get to the point
where we do it with the math,
then they'll really get it.
So that's what I
think we need to do.
That's for my long-term goal.
[LAUGHS]